i'm ainsly your heart i'm brett bear i'm
katie pavlich and this
is the fox news rundown
wednesday may 5th 2021 i'm jessica
rosenthal
we've heard the complaints about big
tech but now some lawmakers say they're
ready to
act introducing legislation that could
alter how social media companies operate
if such laws were to pass congress this
is not trying to
protect or dilute the economic
investment these companies have made
but this is about preventing them from
denying
the right of free speech i'm chris
foster republicans are counting on a big
red wave to take back the house next
year
earlier this year they targeted 47 house
democrats
that they said were vulnerable coming up
in the 22 midterms
now they're upping that by 10 up to 57
house democrats they're going to try to
target
they think that they can flip some of
these seats from blue to red
we speak with fox news national politics
reporter paul steinhauser
i'm liz peake i've got the final word on
the fox news rundown
[Music]
we've been hearing lawmakers talk and
really complain about big tech for a
while now
democrats like senator elizabeth warren
were on the campaign trail in 2019
talking about the need to break up large
social media and tech companies
republicans including at the time
president trump blasted companies like
twitter and facebook
accusing them of censoring conservatives
they talked about repealing their
liability protections
in section 230. the censorship and bias
is a threat to freedom itself
imagine if your phone company silenced
or edited your conversation
social media companies are vastly more
power and more reach than any phone
company in the united states more reach
actually than
your newspapers by far president trump
signed an executive order last spring
that called for
a review of section 230 after twitter
flagged some of his posts
earlier this year twitter ceo jack
dorsey testified before a house
committee
along with the ceos of facebook and
google about disinformation and how they
combat it
revealing that he feels caught between a
rock and a hard place
many of you will have strong opinions on
how effective we are in this work
some of you will say we're doing too
much and removing free speech rights
some of you will say we're not doing
enough and end up causing more harm
both points of view are reasonable and
worth exploring president trump was
banned from twitter and suspended from
facebook after the january 6
capital riots and today facebook will
announce if the former president's
account will be reinstated
it may not matter tuesday trump's team
announced a new platform
it is called from the desk of donald j
trump it reads sort of like a series of
tweets without any user comment or
engagement
now one solution may be coming up with
your own platform but some lawmakers are
now starting to introduce
legislation missouri republican senator
josh hawley told fox and friends this
week
his legislation would break up the tech
and social media companies
we ought to be able to say what we want
to say within the bounds of the law of
course
in this country and the idea that these
corporations would decide what we can't
say and can't say and who can speak and
can't speak
it's it's crazy another piece of
legislation would try to make social
media companies
common carriers well common carries like
a telephone company
what telegraphs used to be rail
tennessee republican senator bill
hagerty
it's basically a a common
sort of platform that the public should
have
non-discriminatory access to and that's
what big tech has become they really
have become sort of our modern day town
square
where people go to get information to
share information they perform a role in
a very similar way except
you know the phone company doesn't like
what you have to say or doesn't like
who you may be or what political party
you're from
they can't just cancel your phone line
right that's not the case
for big tech these days the obama
administration's fcc
classified broadband as a common carrier
that was impacting internet service
providers
apparently they didn't really enforce
strict rules there but they did that
classification as a way to enforce
net neutrality at the time so an
internet service provider couldn't you
know slow down traffic to one site that
maybe say doesn't pay a fee
but under president trump the fcc
repealed
that common carrier status when it
applied to net neutrality
why are you okay with this particular
designation now
for this case well it's because
free speech is what i'm trying to
protect this is not not trying to
protect or dilute the economic
investment these companies have made
but this is about preventing them from
denying
the right of free speech so it's a
different concern
and that's what this censorship does
when they can come in and
fact check and apply you know whatever
lens they use
again it's it's it's opaque it's uh not
shared with people
with with whom you know they've applied
it i was just talking to somebody
earlier today who had been canceled he'd
written once twice three times asking
what were the grounds
no answer no reply this
structure that's in place right now
using section 230
immunity is a way to hide behind it it's
just allowing censorship
of voices that folks at these big tech
platforms disagree with
i want to get to section 230 in a second
but i want to elaborate more on this
idea of censorship and free speech
because
you know you talk about free speech and
we know that the government can infringe
on your right of free speech right
that's what obviously the first
amendment's all about but when you
start applying it to a private company's
ability to moderate its content or
restrict speech
you know where's that line legally
because i imagine these companies will
fight back and say
listen you know we don't have to allow
certain speech well if they're going to
disallow certain speech and this was
actually
contemplated in the uh again we're
getting towards section 230 now but this
was contemplated in
that that act 25 years ago that
that these platforms will be able to
take off you know to address
obscene and lewd sort of uh you know
commentary or or
content but there is a there there's
sort of an extra
you know an extra opening there or
otherwise
disagreeable i believe is the word um
you know
content which is something that these
large tech companies have driven a truck
through that that opening
is far too vague so we need to have
criteria that are much tighter
and you know really address the type of
behavior i think that was intended
in the original 230 rather than having
this open-ended
uh easy to to interpret as you want
type of structure which has been put in
place now to allow
frankly just outright censorship and and
your legislation would repeal 230 right
and we should
inform everybody section 230 use what
limits the liability against these
companies if
a third party writes or says something
that you know
uh somebody objects to the these
companies facebook and google are
protected
legally your legislation would repeal
that 230.
yes it would repeal 230 and it would
replace it with something much tighter
much much less easy to gain and
something that
would prevent the type of censorship
that we've seen today
i've been reading them from keeping a
family family friendly type of
environment that i think was
intended you know in terms of obscene
lewd type of content
but the criteria that they would use it
has to be would have to be made public
that way people can know how the content
that they're receiving is being
moderated
modulated and uh how it's being screened
i've been reading about some of the
fears that repealing 230 sort of invokes
and some folks
uh you know in the tech world um and i'm
my understanding is that there's this
fear that things could then be left up
to the courts
if they didn't have this this particular
protection and a ruling there could
result in even more censorship depending
on the the lawsuit
and you know places as big as like
google and facebook could weather those
consequences you know they've got the
cash
but maybe a smaller upstart would would
not be able to you know if they got sued
without the protections of 230
um so this might end up backfiring they
say and make these tech companies even
more powerful because they could handle
a lawsuit or two you know what do you
think of those concerns yes
you know i'm sensitive to to that
argument jessica that's why we've
made the the the cut off of this of
those platforms that have more than 100
million active monthly users worldwide
got it so again
this this this would this is focused on
the large platforms that really have
become the public square
not on you know not on the nichire
platforms or the upstarts
but that as you as you rightly
underscore
may have difficulty dealing with this
but this would focus on the really large
ones
again in my mind that focus much more
like a common public platform
right you as i noted are just
among a few uh people in congress
putting forth legislation but we know
senator hawley
has done so as well his legislation is i
think it's called the bust up big tech
act and it would it would ban mergers of
companies
worth a certain amount of money and do
things like keep amazon from selling
you know an amazon backed product
alongside a competitor product is this
is this kind of legislation something
you back or could it function alongside
legislation like yours or do we have to
kind of pick
you know i spoke with senator hawley
very briefly last week we just put our
legislation out last week as
as we're leaving for recess and when i
get back
this coming week uh i'm looking forward
to engaging with my
colleagues in the senate to find ways
that we can work together again this is
this is uh
you know my legislation but i'd like to
i'd like to see this past
and you know working with other senators
to get that done is something i'm
looking forward to do and
modifying it incorporating components of
of other
pieces of legislation is something i'm
very receptive to again i have not
studied senator hawley's bill
but we've talked about it at a very high
level so i look forward to engaging with
him and others when i get back to
washington next week
tell me a little bit about what you say
to people who say
look you're talking about regulation
regulation is something we thought
republicans
you know wanted to stay away from you
know get government out of things you're
talking about getting government more
involved
in in something um and this would
obviously not be a free market solution
right why is this the right approach
jessica i'm sensitive to what you're
saying as well i'm the last person that
looks to
government as the answer and more
regulations uh
when you're looking at a problem but
this is a problem that
has become so large as these companies
have become so large
and it really has impacted people in a
way that i think is
is quite unfortunate and when i saw what
was happening you know over the past
year
year and a half where you have these
platforms coming in and
fact checking and canceling you know
people that tend to be conservative
uh by the way but you know fact-checking
american leaders
yet allowing ayatollah khomeini of iran
to talk about debt to israel and talk
about how to how to do it and that
doesn't get
checked or censored you know there
really is a problem there
and it looks like a double standard and
we need to make this
a non-discriminatory uh access point and
and one that's
one where the criteria are equally
applied to all that is depending on
on on free speech in my view and that's
why it's worthy
of again i guess i'm the last person
that looks to a regulatory or a
government answer to things but
this is this is an area where i think
it's appropriate and finally today
facebook's oversight board is going to
announce whether or not former president
trump should have his account reinstated
or if he should be banned permanently
if he is permanently banned what will
that
mean if anything for this debate or is
it just a continuation of this debate
because twitter and facebook
you know were um were all over president
trump while he was president
well in terms of of what it means for
this debate right now i think is a
continuation as you indicated
of a problem that's been mounting but it
but it didn't just start yesterday this
is this is
this is a problem that's been growing
but it's becoming
you know more and more obvious to the
american public and again
whatever decision facebook makes
regarding president trump
uh it's putting this whole concern
into the limelight and reminding
americans that this is a real issue
and the the fact that you've got a panel
that you know resides at one of these
big tech platforms
that is going to make this sort of
decision you know how arbitrary decision
what criteria are they flying is the
same criteria
for president trump that it would be for
someone else these are all questions
that are that are in people's minds
today
because of the epicness of it because
the unfairness of it and the fact that
they don't
uh these platforms uh don't have to
abide by
the type of rule set that a common
carrier would
well senator hagerty thank you so much
for your time jessica thank you
great to be with you
this is liz peek with your fox news
commentary
coming up presidents sometimes have a
short window to work with getting big
things done
president obama for example was able to
get the affordable care act passed with
democrats controlling the house and
senate
they lost the house in 2010 and the
obama agenda was largely stymied even
more so when republicans also took the
senate in 2014.
president trump still had a republican
house and senate to work with when he
was elected and was able to get a huge
tax cut passed during
his first year in office alas in 2018
democrats took back the house
with nancy pelosi becoming speaker to
the speaker of the house
nancy pelosi i extend to you this gavel
thank you very much leader mccarthy i
look forward to working with you in a
bipartisan way
for the good of our country with
democrats also winning the white house
and the senate in last year's elections
by slim margins
president biden has a window of
opportunity now but it's not very big
and it may not last long
top house republican kevin mccarthy
predicts he'll be speaker next year
telling the political conservative
action conference in february
i would bet my house this is the
smallest
majority the democrats have had in a
hundred years
we could do it and history's on his side
you know traditionally in the midterm
elections
the party that controls the white house
loses anywhere from about 25 to 30 seats
in the house
that's a problem for the democrats
because joe biden is in the white house
right now so
history is not working on the democratic
side right now fox news
national politics reporter paul
steinhauser redistricting alone
may be the ticket for the republicans
winning back the majority
and if you look at the early numbers
that came out of the census just
last week you see that some big
republican states where the republicans
control all the levels of government
texas think florida they're gaining
seats
states where the democrats can rule the
rules think new york illinois california
they're going to be losing seats thanks
to the 2020
census and because of that the national
republican congressional committee
known by its acronym the nrcc that's the
re-election arm of house republicans
they're upping their targets now they
earlier this year they targeted
47 house democrats that they said were
vulnerable
coming up in the 22 midterms now they're
upping that by 10.
up to 57 house democrats they're going
to try to target
they think that they can flip some of
these seats from blue to red
and a lot of these 10 that were just
added were added because of the census
report and they're from those states
that we just
talked about new york illinois and
california
targeting meaning more money more
attention in those races
exactly these are the seats they're
going to concentrate on the republicans
are going to
concentrate on these democrats or they
think they can flip these seats from
blue to red
uh you'll see digital ads tv ads radio
by the nrcc and also by outside groups
that uh
back republicans look at the senate for
a minute too um
over the last 80 years or whatever the
president's party has lost
senate seats in most of the midterm
elections not all it didn't happen in
2018
the republicans actually picked up some
part of that was just a function
of the map that year uh it just was a
better republican year
which states can we see to be really
contested that we might not think would
have been contested
next year yeah and here's the beauty of
you think that the margins are narrow in
the house that they are
even more narrow in the senate right
it's a 50-50 senate right now but the
republicans
are in the minority the democrats are in
the majority because kamala harris the
vice president is a democrat so they get
that extra tie-breaking vote
republicans so when you look at the map
they only need a net gain of one to
regain the majority
but they are defending 20 of the 34
seats up for grabs in 2022
so they're playing a lot of defense uh
and in some states
they're going to be defending an open
seat think pennsylvania and north
carolina
two crucial battleground states
republican senators there are retiring
republicans definitely got their work
cut out for them but
here's the flip side and it's a big but
there are four states where the
republicans think they have a very good
shot of flipping a blue seat red and
those those four senators are raphael
warnock in georgia he was just elected
remember it back in january
and that uh in the runoff election down
there mark kelly
in arizona also just elected uh in
november to a just a two-year term a
special election
and then two other democrats who they
think are very vulnerable
we're talking about maggie hassan first
term senator from new hampshire
and cortez mastro in nevada so
republicans think they have a clear shot
here they're looking at those four
states
that's where they're going to be
targeting looking at the republicans
right now we could see a shakeup in
leadership the ghost of president trump
is still
affecting things representative liz
cheney from wyoming
has said look president trump lied about
the election being stolen
she's been attacking him in person in
speeches on social media president trump
is
attacking her back as he can through
memos now now that he's off social media
and there are people in the republican
party in the house who want her to
be removed from her leadership our house
minority leader mccarthy
is saying that she can't carry out the
party's message anymore so
what happens did is her successor
necessarily going to be somebody who was
more
you know aligned with president trump
this is a huge
intra-party battle on the republican
side right here and it's grabbing a
ton a ton of attention uh both in the
media and on social media you name it
this is a huge story right now and it
also shows just how
popular donald trump remains with
republican-based voters and how
influential
and how much clout he still has over gop
politicians
that were in this place right now
earlier this year
trump loyalists in the house tried to
boot cheney from her number three
position
in the house conference but they were
unsuccessful she easily crushed it
but times have changed that was like two
or three months ago
and i i think the former president's
cloud is even more stronger now than it
was
then and mccarthy who defended cheney
back in january and february during that
first push to ouster from her leadership
position
is not doing that anymore and it's
questioning whether she can
effectively be a good messenger for the
republican house conference
anymore because when it comes to donald
trump she doesn't see eye to eye
with the vast majority of house
republicans
so the votes weren't uh with the trump
loyalists
last time they may be this time plus
cheney's up for re-election just like
everybody else in the house they're up
every two years
so she faces re-election next year and
there is a concerted effort by donald
trump and his political team
to find a single challenger to
get behind to try and oust her next year
and wyoming is a state that donald trump
did extremely well and so
cheney's facing a number of problems on
a number of fronts
yeah um the president said on his way
out the door look if you weren't with me
you're against me and i'm gonna use my
money and my
megaphone to go after your seat next
time yep
and it's not just chedi also think about
lisa murkowski
there were seven senate republicans who
voted to convict donald trump in that
impeachment trial back in february
she's the only one of those seven
republicans who's up for re-election
next year
trump has vowed to go after her and he's
also vowing to come back to georgia
and campaign against the republican
governor there brian kemp who used to be
a huge trump
loyalist but trump blames kemp for not
helping him as he tried to up end and
overturn
the election results in georgia where
joe biden had a narrow victory over
donald trump back in november
i mean as usual this time of a
presidential cycle there are umpteen
people
um teen republicans that are interested
in throwing their hat in the ring but
they can't
because president trump is still out
there saying i'm thinking about running
again
is that going to hurt them in terms of
getting their operations up and running
and in terms of fundraising if big
donors say look i'm not i'm not
committing to anybody until we know what
trump's doing
well no on the fundraising for a little
bit but it seems to a degree yes
i mean as the former president teases
repeatedly teases and flirts with
another run in 2024 to try to regain the
white house
that is slowing down the field a bit but
it's not stopping it all together
former vice president mike pence making
some news this week fox news
first report that pence will be heading
in early june
to headline a major fundraising dinner
for the new hampshire republicans and of
course new hampshire the first in nation
presidential primary state
and just last week he gave his first
speech
since leaving the administration since
the end of the trump administration and
where did he give that speech
in south carolina that's one of the
other early voting states they go third
in the republican calendar and it's the
first
southern primary so pence definitely
starting to
you know spark speculation about 2024
with these visits and he's not the only
one
mike pompeo trump's secretary of state
during the trump administration
uh has already been to iowa so has two
senators named scott
tim scott of south carolina rick scott
of florida two others we think of
as potential contenders iowa of course
is the state that kicks off the primary
process with its caucuses
and nikki haley the former south
carolina governor she's heading to iowa
coming up soon
tom cotton has also been very visible as
well as some others
so yeah trump has slowed the field down
but he's not stopping these other
potential contenders for the white house
from starting to make those early moves
and uh apologies to listeners who are
irritated that we're talking about
a presidential election that's three and
a half years away that's just sometimes
how it works
when we do this paul there was a special
election in texas
for a house seat it's called the jungle
election that is where republicans
and democrats were all in the same field
two republicans made it to the runoff a
democrat
barely finished third but republicans
really outpaced democrats
in total of all the candidates 62
percent of the vote to 37 percent
i know special elections are weird and
it's just one state
but does that special election say
anything about what could happen in 2022
it might sometimes special elections are
a good barometer of things to come
sometimes they're a terrible barometer
so we won't know until november of 2022
but here's why republicans are growing
right now over this past weekend's
results down there in that sixth
congressional district of texas
don wright was the congressman the
republican congressman in the district
won reelection last year by single
digits and donald trump
only carried the district which starts
in the suburbs and parts of the southern
part of fort worth
uh and then goes further south into the
exurbs and the rural areas
south of fort worth and dallas trump
only want to buy two or three points
so democrats looked at this district and
said this is a competitive district
this is maybe we maybe we have a chance
of flipping a red seat flue here
didn't happen obviously as you mentioned
with those results and that's why
republicans are saying
this is a sign folks that hey texas
isn't turning blue anytime soon and b
joe biden is unpopular and the democrats
are going to lose the house in 2022.
do they have a case to make there yeah
of course they do but again
we won't know it's only one special
election sometimes they get it right
sometimes they get it wrong
very early reasons for republican
optimism looking at next year's midterms
with fox news national politics reporter
paul steinhauser paul thanks for coming
back on the rundown good to talk to you
great to join you guys thank you
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic publisher of the federalists
and i'm inviting you to join a new
conversation with the smartest thinkers
out there
about the country and where we're going
subscribe to the ben dominic podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
liz peek
what's on your mind well this is
confusing
after a year of slamming the united
states as systemically
racist president biden now says
i don't think the american people are
racist come again
how could a country be racist if its
people are not
surely a country cannot be racist if
it's people twice elected a black
president
or if they back policies demanding
equality
we have laws banning discrimination we
have jury trials that convict white cops
who kill black men
and we have schools religious
organizations neighborhoods and
political
parties that are open to all biden made
his head spinning comment
in an interview with nbc when asked to
respond to tim scott's declaration
that america is not a racist country
twice
the president agreed with the republican
senator from south carolina
maybe joe biden and kamala harris who
has recently
also said america is not a racist
country
are backpedaling because they realize
they've overplayed the race card
polling shows americans concern about
racism has dropped sharply in recent
months
even as worries about immigration
unemployment
and budget deficits have soared race is
important to democrats who count on
receiving roughly 90 percent of the
black vote
it is especially important to joe biden
if not for african-americans handing him
the democratic primary
in south carolina he would not be
president
a recent poll from harvard's kennedy
school institute of politics
may shed some light on biden and harris
is surprising about
face it shows 46 percent of young
americans feel
quote included in blind america unquote
including 61 percent of blacks and 51
percent of hispanics
however only 39 percent of whites felt
that biden's america was
hospitable to them surely
disenfranchising young white voters
cannot work well for democrats
a bigger problem for democrats though is
the success and popularity of a black
conservative like tim scott
scott can speak to racism which does
exist in america
as it does in every country of the world
but scott can also attribute his success
to quote
a string of opportunities that are
possible only here in america
unquote democrats do not want
young black kids to know that if they
work hard and get a good education
the sky is the limit first that would
crimp their ambition to vastly grow the
welfare state
second it turns the spotlight on the
teachers unions and on the failures of
our inner city public schools
scott said education is the closest
thing to magic
in america tragically not all minority
kids can access that magic
americans are proud of our country
including its remarkable history of
lifting up
all kinds of people joe biden has it
right
we are not a racist people this is liz
peek
fox news contributor
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown rundown stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
fox nation presents podcasts women of
the bible speak
i'm shannon breem host of fox news at
night and author of the new book women
of the bible speak the wisdom of 16
women and their
lessons for today subscribe now on apple
podcast spotify
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you
download your podcasts
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes